partito sono partito ciao amici
introduzione mamma mi avete stordito
dalle che grazie ragazzi sono con pietro
è ciccio è oggi facciamo video su un
gioco che se unite tutte le mappe
insieme di sto gioco arriviamo un
quoziente intellettivo inferiore a tre
cifre ed è quello che noi sappiamo fare
bene ragazzi miei amici mi vogliono un
sacco bene quando io faccio delle
battute anche pietose loro ridono un
sacco perché voglio non sa come sapete
cosa ci fanno otto cani in mare un
canotto ragazzi comunque parte questo
hanno fatto la nuova per il man for flat
e volevamo giocarla a tutti e 3 posto io
io so come funzionano mi riconobbe
comandi ciao amici che l'ho mai fatto
stanotte legal anche tantissimo me non
importa andiamo aprite la porta
aiutatemi cosa abbiamo allora
l'obiettivo l'obiettivo è quello di come
uscire da questo posto è capito ok ma no
no ed eviti gli apre la porta non lo so
non mi chiedo allora lasciami che già è
difficile apre la porta ios aver
guardato guardata da ecco bravo
aspettati che questa in testa magari se
ritieni non rompe le balle tutto rimane
non basta dire magari ci schiacciano
schiacciano pacifici contro poi mollarmi
lurido server con la cacciano club di
ritirare le mani in alto e aggrapparti
però non è così facile ma ci sono
proprio così ma mai ci si piazza la
palla ma fatica stati in uno alla volta
uno alla volta di pace agli amici che
non concede a pietro fammi un favore
lascia la cassa alza la casa sulla cassa
ma è troppo presa migliore è spenta
rimane così no rimane così telefona
dovresti sollevarmi la cassa e
mettermela un po più sotto il deretano
forse vittime la sotto il deretano che
bravo sei così sta così dai così non
serve non scendi porca vacca ce l'ha
fatta ma non serve vieni qua qua ra
genoma lui faceva fare secondo me
quanto è difficile questa nuova mappa
allora dieci minuti per uscire dalla
prima ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta ben i
veri signori dopo due ore e mezza ce
l'abbiamo fatta
la prima parte ora bilanci rilascia è
sfondata la porta lascia sfonda la porta
pietro te la lascio giuro ok bilancio in
giro perché oggi riess pieni quando alla
porta ma io posso scala chiari come se
andate a d'altra parte della porta ma
non fai l'uomo facciamo caso io la posso
liberarmi qua e poi aprite la porta
merito c'è un aiuto apribili se ne frega
giochiamo con ben bene siamo usciti da
amici posso battermi altro mi sa abbatti
l'albero oddio non ci credo veramente
l'ora che abbracci se vieni qua c
[Musica]
no no fai schifo veramente bravi davanti
rimossa e bellissimo per lo faccio la
cosa fortissimo e penso che risparmia
anche l'oggetto come fatta è scaduta
tecnica della per il testa a testa tetto
ai è difficilissimo in je te lo sa
quanto costa
no no no no no questo mai ci viene dai
sei un bravo no no bravo ti puoi
aggrappare all'albero e tirati sopra
roma il cavolo non ritrovarci sono
bellissimi era leghiste cosa no e qui
fai schifo ma vai via qualcuno va bene
in tutto questo
cicero esplorato quindi andati a dar
fuoco alle cose giuste dai popoli in
mezzo dai fuoco di me
bravo mamma mia la temperatura non so
cosa serva sta roba vero a cosa serve
sta roba qua la pace una porta
ragioniera non c'è una porta bisogna
prenderla
non è che non va sottaciuto la porta in
legno la porta serve una chiave per la
poi alla corte di legno a dobbiamo
forgiare la chiave ragazzi cavo guarda
come il film urlando siamo veramente
bravi e è vero c'è ancora da pescara
picardi devi devi aggrapparti così lo
vedi la levetta tutta giu l'area giochi
scusami tutta la moutte lo stesso
aprendo stesso principio dalla vetta con
cui ti tiri deve andare tutto cioè devi
immaginare che ti tiri su con le braccia
dalle vetta va tutta gioco io non come
ho fatto io adesso malati malati ma
arriva da pina mar arriva da una mano
viene apposto amico
bisogna mettere le pietre qua ma non ho
capito bene cosa dovrebbe servire come
stiamo vedendo anche oblò gli alieni
portale pietà ecco vedi che c'è
l'ascensore va giù a si stappata sta
roba
non lo so io sono davanti ragazzi non
sono sto facendo esattamente non parla
ciccio guardami aree vive di così e poi
ti tiri su cavie infatti solo detto
molto bravo è bravo e non viaggiano da
soli fa non vedo cosa c'è di andare qua
di là dove si fa il possibile vedere
come si esalta sull'albero salta
sull'albero ma che è prova tagliati lo
faccio io ma che bravo ciccio ciao
ciccio parla così è vero è molto
difficile saltare sull'albero e invece
ce la fa proprio lui incredibile sono
stavo cadendo sotto meno male non dico
forse va da un'altra parte legata ok ho
trovato e ci dall'altra parte c'è
un'altra fetta forma venite venite è una
parola veni mamma mia quanto lenti io
sono partito con l'albero ma che cit
ma sì ma solo fortissimo guarda che
bravo io pc parco dovrà ancora più
difficile pensate voi come ancora per
rifiutarsi se non ci arrivo io non ci
arriva nessuno povero di quei ragazzi
sono arrivato in cima sono bravissimo e
ora è ora vuole solo perché figata vedo
tutto aspettato che credo serve fare qua
poi c'è un orologio a cosa serve solo
logio marchingegno a posso girare
l'orologio a cosa serve ecco lo è
fate cascata la chiave ragazzi anzi no è
cascata la chiave di sotto di sopra sarà
presa eccomi scendete ce l'hai perfetto
vieni vieni qui vieni vieni ciccio a
porta le chiavi ciccio devi infilare la
chiave era e aspetta la chiave nel buco
bravo ci sarà proprio la guardi
interessato a lei appare bravo ora in
fila lamberti la chiave no no non li do
a noli in fila in fila baciccio bravo e
apprezzato l'impegno non bisognava
abbiamo scoperto guardando video sul
tema che non capivamo mentre sti due
ballano che non va solo inserita la
chiave lamento di farla fondere ma qua
c'è una miniera dove bisogna prendere la
croce del carbone io lo tiro fuori
poi prendete il carbonia e lo mettete
nella fornace io vado a vedere cosa c'è
di male che qua c'è qualcos'altro
ragazzi e ragazze sono andato in un
punto ancora più avanti torna a quale mi
ha fatto già scavalcare il cancello non
so come sia possibile ti guardo aprì la
porta di guardare come cosa ci ridono
sopra e si poteva e si poteva passare
anche senza non so come aprite st porta
schifosa e soprattutto papiccio
controchiave allora i complimenti un'ora
e mezza di porta
adesso c'è un ponte cadore se siete
quindi io direi che possiamo andare dove
dove sono arrivato io ma non erano era
semplicemente un trick per andare più
avanti o no cosa sta succedendo
che figata c'è un carrello venite amici
no fermi no
l'ultimo pietra rimasta di e indietro
ciceri a occhio che ci siamo davanti
dove hanno fatto cadere ragazzo
cantalini dietro pietro ma allora ok la
facciamo
ho fatto una cosa incredibile tu non lo
so provaci
l'importante è crederci nella vita dove
ti ha fatto ripartire ma sono cose
qualcuno te io no io sono caduto che
pirla praga difficilissimo cioè no sei
una persona che vi fa venire il
voltastomaco io te lo giuro
bravo cicciolo dollari donati bravo
bravo piaccia euro 6 sta roba qua tutto
sto casino sarebbero per alzare un ponte
fitti vere anzi ho premuto parole c'è
forse correct poi grazie signore in
avanti grazie mille e però dobbiamo
attivare la corrente prima
dell'ascensore ragazzi del generatore di
corrente va in giro e lancia una
batteria qua c'è una batteria e one è
quello lassere per ricaricare le
batterie capitò a guardar giocare pietro
ragazzi mi sono caduti i capelli però ok
va beh comunque noi ragazzi continuiamo
nel prossimo episodio con il finale
della mappa di human flat sesto gioco
avesse cento mappe sarebbe più popolare
di four nights punto quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto ci vediamo al
proseguito di human free flat se vi è
piaciuto il video lasciate mi piace ma
tanto che è piaciuto perché seguite
memika seguite inserire qui nome di
youtube era cui fare di singh è quindi
iscriviti al canale era civili ha come
sempre proposto da ragazzi
[Musica]